welcome to this video playing speedster
from the u.s. Sicilian okay hey going
further okay not the Kalashnikov yeah
maybe g6 I don't know maybe you should
to place the form i can actually pre
move that for nope just wants to develop
stuff this this kind of development is
not very popular but it's not bad at all
there is the the cup of variation of the
english opening c-45 with the later
Bishop c5 which is considered very very
solid and this is just the same thing
with colors reversed so it's not a bad
opening at all just hmm yeah that is
uncommon it's this kind of this opening
of the position very very early then it
opens up the long diagonal actually for
black so it's kind of fun it's kind of
unusual yeah okay moving the night is
not really helping me a lot
let's try for Bishop to be 723 rugby aid
and then we should be seven looks okay
not quite sure where else to put the
bishops on Bishop e7 should be an okay
move how does he try to do simply
trading off all pieces off and let me
this this looks really wrong b5 or say I
can it looks like there's some way to be
five yes b5 he has to play Bishop b3
let's do that first and then it gains
some skate sometime Bishop f6 is just
double attacking then Bishop f6 and I'm
double attacking rook and Bishop so he
has to go Bishop b3 that's the only move
and what then should be three I don't
see likessee for this is the tactics
there should be seven he can take
doesn't look like there is a really
great tactic here there should be seven
another seven Bishop f7 rook c5 it's not
working and see if c4 c4 is very close
to working really is okay I spent huge
time and I'll blundering 90s have no
this is stupid after this totally we had
setup 97 you can just take 97 roll okay
maybe that's not so clear but it's still
completely unnecessary yeah I should
have played something hanging okay it's
not taking less you go back to e 1 i'm
threading c4 of course so we cannot go
to e2 or something rookie one only move
ok rock t5 maybe maybe you can play this
weird move but he when he wants to
obviously play the weirdest possible
moves that are not losing immediately so
Luke t5 kind of fits their mo after c4
is playing hook see five years
unbelievable itself
so see for Roxy five
that's difficult not to play the move so
Luke c5 can do to a 60 is not to play
whoopsie 5 is taken first
it's one of the wackiest games in a
while this kind of weird rook maneuvers
and so on nobody nobody understands
what's going on really weird stuff yeah
at least is not he has not played at all
instantly which would be the normal way
and they they play those weird stuff
like meet Leah not even spending a
second thought goof okay maybe and
already I should've taken be to
immediately okay thanks here taking be
to achieve a check be 3 i'm opening up
the a file which are not sure about okay
where am I going now may I know I can
take I still will take a seven
remarkably
try and for f4
I try to get active activity here with
rook t2 i have to get one of those pawns
otherwise the two connected pawns will
will kill me this might lead to the same
thing which I mean ultimately to defeat
I mean but I have to try time morning
I don't know Bishop a seven looked very
simple didn't do didn't do that one
check maybe this is winning as well but
check no I'm all of a sudden getting
pretty confident yeah he's just blending
blundering the whole house who h1
checkmate no I humming massage I was
beard from a lost end came to her to win
in five moves or so hmm yeah don't know
this was a very weird game yeah 95 what
is there is a very strange move so how
do i play this 95 is the strongest yeah
the simple moves rook takes and queens 7
and now the rook the look at doesn't
have any good squares yeah this is much
easier this is already a very cleared
from like minus 1.8 as 0.8 I'm sorry
okay this is fancy but not good he would
treat it and simply a simply blundered
97 yeah this is stupid right I was
thinking that there should be some kind
of way with c4 his queen it's not
protected so let's say here and we he's
in an inner he's in a pin here in a way
but there is no way to use that thing
check no he took that i thot 97 action
yeah but i mean this is not a clear this
is not clear or anything but I'm still
checking stuff and Peele in this and see
form ok ok now we played the rock g5 we
had yeah but it is ok it seems to be ok
I mean his look has no squared oh yeah
it's gone all protected it's just in the
middle of nowhere
but it seems to be okay yeah no chinks
chinks and white white is just better
here yeah there's no no question at all
he has two points here now the connected
passes and an extra for that it's mostly
the two connected points that are the
problem yeah I tried this this desperate
call to play and the the weird part is
when we go up here I took b5 back and
Bishop a7 is just this is just promoting
there is nothing i can do i can just
resign move 30 33 he played this and now
nothing's clear f2 hangs with check yeah
auntie em jack black is better at tea
I'm just winning the house yeah amazing
so it's really strange Bishop a7 would
have would have won rather rather easily
I was a lucky win thanks for watching